roughly a year after Brooklyn Beckham
and Nicola Peltz said I do a new lawsuit
alleges shocking details in the lead-up
to their big day I don't have the words
fans also left speechless after reports
of behind the scenes drama from their
April wedding Nelson Peltz Nicola's
father suing wedding planners who were
fired after nine days on the job for
allegedly not refunding him a nearly 160
thousand dollar deposit
Brooklyn's dad is soccer Superstar David
Beckham his mom Victoria a clothing
designer and former Spice Girl we love
our kids and we want the best for them
we're hearing Nicola and Brooklyn's
parents were very close at first but the
wedding planning led to tension between
them due to Brooklyn not spending as
much time with his family I have seven
siblings so I think he he loves being
with my family and just being around so
many boys I think he has like built-in
boy best friends now and those wedding
planners they're filing a countersuit
against nichola's dad in Court docs
obtained by E.T details emerge from
Brooklyn and Nicola's three million
dollar wedding those allegations include
an evolving guest list from the peltzes
lack of direct communication from Nicola
and out of control spending like a
hundred thousand dollars in travel
expenses just for Nicola's hair and
makeup team nothing comes away in the
way of our children so they're our
priority ahead of the wedding et's
Insider says there were arguments about
various aspects of the celebration which
caused some friction among the families
one of the pop culture moments of 2022
was your unbelievable wedding
congratulations five months in does it
feel different
um it does feel different you know like
I think like you know I married my best
mate and it's the best feeling in the
world and you know it's just me and her
we do our own thing we work we both work
like every day meanwhile The Source
tells us the newlyweds are happy in
their relationship and things between
them have gotten better as they've
matured and settled into married life
Brooklyn's truly like my best friend and
I feel like I'm living with my best
friend and also like the love of my life
so it's been nice
foreign
[Music]